hi there reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey I'm
Jason Tolin Jason top.i Jason Dolan good
friend of ours go follow him on
Instagram as I do and he also wrote a
movie starring Matt Logan Marshall
Greene local urban Logan Lerman goddamn
it now Liam Paul either he's a really
nice guy Logan Lerman Kyle Chandler
they'll show Monaghan Nell Fanning
called The Vanishing to Sydney all
really good film you guys should go
check it out on Amazon I'm ensign so my
brother Jabby Kawai asked me to check
out his vlog that he put together
recently it's called after India vlog
number 30 I think that he's in Thailand
description says so a number of you have
joked around me about how long it's
taken for all my vlogs from my 2017 trip
to come out well I stay committed to
gain and done and this is the final vlog
from that trip so he went from LA to
Dubai Abu Dhabi OH
Dubai yeah to India to Thailand so yeah
he wants to check it out because he's
struggling right now on YouTube he's not
doing well and he just needs a little
boost from our much more superior
channel I understand that you're welcome
you're welcome this is a favor to help
you out because you're you're struggling
so much it's the last morning in India
right now before we leave for Thailand
[Music]
like I'm there I want to go there
[Music]
it looks like it was easy to put
together
hey there's one big one
[Music]
and these intercourse like awesome I
know so it's just think everyone is mrs.
Tywin or India
[Music]
he paid $1,000 for the licensing rights
for this Wow glad I wrote it you did
great job trying to viewers
extraordinaire what I do in my spare
time I could actually see you just
surrounded by keyboards now it's funny I
have two friends that like or have lived
in Thailand and they're always telling
me to go there this makes me want to go
there
guitarists time
she get a cigar three
[Music]
Zhang wig
[Music]
is this largest of big ma yeah you know
ours
[Music]
[Music]
set him some random attaboy I love those
hilarious personalized license plates
get away ride my motorcycle on the
screen problem I'm about to see my
friend Paula Lulu's here tonight I
haven't seen mom in a while she's one of
my closest friends that I've known for
years and years we do it's like as if no
time has passed at all it's pretty crazy
to be your girlfriend over 10 years
[Music]
Oh fun it doesn't look like a Christian
[Music]
sir crime goes down
[Music]
you're getting paid to advertise my land
or something all right
because said the nation of Thailand's
marks this video like it's like spice
Hemsworth and Danny McBride are gonna
show up you know
brought you by the time film
were these random woman assuming
sensations agogo
it's probably a library
[Music]
[Music]
so this is Benihana essentially it's a
real flame you know right there you're
gonna ten minutes of waves and having to
go this is charge a be drunk is special
traveling is discussed mastering your
friend cookies I can't
it's like a old friend cookies the old
friend cookies yo you guys have heard of
talking right most of you were to party
this is hockey traditionally speaking
good night most familiar with the
variation strawberry I can't didn't
excellent portion or pizza version this
is pretty really pretty good then you
start to get into weird things when
you're in another country I believe it's
a shrink so as you can see here people
have been buying this which means that
it's actually a popular flavor who do
they go Pretz
lard biscuit sister do you want to eat a
snack that tastes like onion meat salad
is one domestic
on States you've got Lay's baked chips
or Lay's potato chips with your barbecue
flavor flavor flavor Zoltan Sealy
Pringles
I like I want some of this Celia I've
seen the original like we they better be
paying you so much money that looks
really good to me
America I don't like politics of my
youtube videos yeah especially when
their vlogs about life when it comes to
my vlogs which is an interrupting this
one so I can explain to you what's about
to come next in this video and doing
that when it comes to my blogs I feel
like you know I got and I do my best to
put it together in a fun compelling
exciting way and if it works awesome
it doesn't that's just sometimes what's
about to come next I really feel like
I've got to give you guys context and
explanation so you understand why it was
important for me to include it in this
video I grew up playing a video game
called Street Fighter 2 you may have
heard me make references to it you may
have even seen my joke references to it
and in the game there are two bosses
from Thailand in bison and Sagat the
whole reason why we were in Thailand at
all was because it was a charas sister's
wedding but for me in addition to that
one of the most exciting things about
going to Thailand was to be able to
visit the god and invites in stages in
real life oh cool fortunately there
wasn't enough time
and bison stage it was too far away and
there's a lot of events going on but
there was just enough time to go to
Sagat stage so we asked chars mom where
is it she thought it was this one spot
cuz it had this giant leaning Buddha but
it was the wrong location I'm gonna show
that to you anyway because I think it's
still beautiful it's still awesome and
mesmerizing and then she directed us to
the right spot which was actually much
further away for me I almost had tears
in my eyes when we weren't there I don't
have footage to prove that but you're
just gonna have to take my word for it
because you mucking liar everyone's a
seasick on stage I realize now I'm
better than all you liar
that location so that stage is also
where they shot the opening scene in
Mortal Kombat
so we really have multiple reasons why
it's cool to share this with you guys
[Music]
stage always that thing is in the
background it's cuts it
[Music]
it would be fun to go to Thailand but
it's also nice going at Denny's just
sank we can go to eat
- a lot of Denny's on the way out here
and all of our hotels at Denny's thanks
Jen dad you remember that thanks people
of this episode come apologize son what
oh my god Aaron is my dad loves tideland
dude he was in Vietnam
dad okay I thought the other thing was
the stage I feel dumb wow that's cool oh
[Music]
that's why the mom thought that was a
good okay I make that the context helps
it's cool they base it on a real place
there's the Mortal Kombat stage now is
Jabby gonna go up and pick our random
fight with somebody yeah okay so yeah we
get grace like Power Move if he lost
he's not gonna put it in there that's
right
so let's just assume he lost yeah sorry
buddy train next better next time hope
that's the guy
beat him up more sense now
[Music]
now one street fighter pose not one pose
is looking too bright you know I'm like
I want to see a flying kick across the
screen oh maybe this is it this is a guy
that made the spiders ha yes that it
yeah oh wow we didn't go in this that's
the beginning of a smart people sermon
well have you seen any of Jabby coins
before I've not seen any of his blogs so
now I'm actually can I go check some of
them out so you like this this actually
made me like I if it's world tours and
seeing places I've never seen before
you know if it's just his kitchen you
know making seaweed sushi flavoured his
kitchen before well I have not seen his
kitchen so maybe I need to watch that
vlog like you've been to our old
apartment that's right
his kitchen is almost identical now he
works his asses off his asses several
asses they working them all off what is
that in this no he's really particular
about making sure that the music is
properly edited to the imagery and the
cuts and that's always the most
impressive to me about this you know I'm
gonna would like to have them like
review this this is a little bit more
interaction with people and I wanted to
see him get beat up by I wanted more
than any big dangerous
I think bodies that's exactly what he
found in that cave and that's why he cut
it out because he realized after what
happened can't go through it even though
he's got Asian blood in him Israel would
not pass cuz he's not Thai no this is
really well shot that's a lot of fruit
goddamn it's like a full-on documentary
you made here I know how much time did
this tape two-headed did you yell at a
Chara did you have her edit this really
make it this way no uh you have our
sister edit their sister that it's right
on that oh wow one of the asses yeah
yeah one of the many so they calls
editors you are the asses of this
operation and we are going to work
everything we do reactions to jab easy
knows we bring you the the behind the
scenes truths what's behind asses behind
this yeah he's he's not emotionally
abusive he's very physically abusive but
as long as not emotionally abusive
there's no long-term effects and I just
wanted to see him like interact more
with people like when he went to go see
his from Paulo I don't see a little bit
more than interaction you know like I
liked when he was shopping around the
store but what would sushi flavor be I
mean there's so much like different
kinds of sushi you like what would
category
yeah well specifically the Kleenex comes
out of the nose I wonder if in the
bathroom the toilet paper comes out of a
but oh me that's what I want to do yeah
I also got a go to time right now right
Thailand is also known for prostitution
oh is it a red-light districts yeah I
mean they said players called sensations
he was taking that was a lie what I was
before we're studying
typhoons biggest library yes I hear
everybody in Thailand very well read
stick your fingers in a buck you know
but it was cool that he got a got
seasick on stage yeah I probably the
ultimate highlight it's gonna Taeyang
winter really well with the new Mortal
Kombat hi NC dude look at us just honey
we're so good this is the reaction he
was hoping for
yes get ready to watch your subscriber
count' finally have a bump yeah get
ready for that 2 billion subscriber mark
coming for you he reacts to as many
videos of ours as we react is it [ __ ] it
it's a fair ritual exchange it's a fair
fight
sponsorship oh yeah dad that since
you're part of the Asus exactly yeah I'm
one of the asses an extended ass the
defining asset the finding of this
operation satellite I hope you got paid
something from one of these companies
that you promoted here or you get sued
from one of these exactly either one
will make me feel satisfied the next
time I go to Thailand if I see sushi
flavored potato chips I'm gonna give
they are ripping your brain off no you
should just send him a crate sent him
like a lifetime supply they won't know
what to do with maybe I'll just like
mail them some sushi in just an envelope
to drop in a couple of pieces newspaper
he sleeps with the sushi now that's more
of an insult to the mailman I guarantee
you that he probably got really drunk
that night and drunk Jabby I think the
one time I met Jabby he was that's right
totally different human being yeah my
impression of a drunk javi is either
like just incredibly happy or very
sleepy yeah that's that's a lot of drunk
people you know or just dreaming happy
yeah you think you get like angry but
now alright guys well if you haven't
subscribed to the jab eco a channel go
there today he does stuffy's a writer we
all know that John and Gregor here we're
asses like bells there you go
we lost the footage for the shout out
here that we wanted to do for Kurt
Anderson so we're gonna do it here on
the phone hey buddy Kurt Anderson pitch
from the day shout out for anybody he is
the perfect person to shout out in this
travel vlog because like we've pointed
out several times for this guy he is a
nomad he's a dude who's always
travelling the world but very recently
he specifically told me he will be
ending his life on the road sort of he's
going to the road but by keeping his
card on file still so we're safe he's
planning on by moving to Brazil and I've
been doing this wonder thing for a
better part of a decade I think it's
time to sit still for a year or two he
loves South America in Brazil in
particular so it feels right oh God good
for you dude I'm happy you're gonna be
settling down I hope you fulfilled your
plan and impregnated one chick in every
single state in America and at least one
woman in every part of the world in all
the other countries because that is the
ultimate goal and then by the time you
die you will have an army of children
ready to continue on and they will do
the same thing you are forming your own
version of real life multi-level
marketing one thousand dollars without
marketing just a deadly army of Kurt
Anderson's hey make sure to get a wax
while you're down there you can't die if
you're nuts I mean you got to be silky
smooth especially if you're gonna make
this child army I mean what better way
to do that than with a fresh Brazilian
wax man so do it up
you take some coke or something pingzhi
guy